do it anyway is a mindset trick that you
can use when you start to feel excuses
rolling up it works a lot like the
five-second rule so you have said to
yourself okay i'm gonna talk to my boss
today about that thing that i've been
avoiding talking to them about or maybe
you've said something like i'm gonna go
to the gym today or tomorrow or whatever
and then the moment comes where you've
gotta have that conversation where the
moment comes where it's time to pack up
your bag and leave your desk and go to
the gym and what always happens you
don't feel like it i bet there are
plenty of you watching that have made a
commitment that i'm not gonna have a
drink tonight and then guess what
happens when you get home you don't feel
like not drinking you feel like having a
drink and so here's what do it anyway
has done for me the idea that i just do
it anyway has pushed me to realize and
to recognize that there are a lot of
moments where there are things in my
life that i really want to do i need to
do i should do but when the moment comes
i don't feel like it and so i pull out
this idea of you know what i'm just
gonna do it anyway it's raining outside
i said i would go for a short run i
don't feel like it i'm gonna do it
anyway it's six o'clock in the morning
i'm tired it's cold i laid out my yoga
clothes but now i don't feel like it
what do i do i do it anyway when you
start to say to yourself i'm gonna do it
anyway what happens is something really
cool you acknowledge that there are
feelings that you have that are trying
to swoop in and hijack you you
acknowledge them and you basically say
guess what i'm gonna do it anyway most
people don't hit their big goals because
they don't believe that they can because
you've trained yourself that when you
set a goal and when it gets hard you
quit
if you're on a diet and that food comes
in and it smells oh so good you eat it
you're training yourself that you set
goals and don't follow through you set
goals and you don't follow through you
set an alarm to wake up at a certain
time and you hit the snooze button first
thing in the morning you set a goal and
you did not follow through and so now
when you set new goals you've trained
yourself you've conditioned yourself
that i'm the kind of person who doesn't
follow through so instead of do it
anyway i'd switch it to do it because i
said i would
sticking with your goals doing it when
it's hard that's how you build
self-respect self-esteem and
self-confidence so let me use myself as
an example today i am on a ketogenic and
intermittent fasting diet which means i
eat keto so it means i can't eat a lot
of different foods got to stay healthy
and i eat starting at 2 p.m and ending
at 8 p.m so in that six hour windows
when i eat and the other 18 hours i'm
fasting that makes it really tough so
today especially was difficult for
whatever reason today was extremely
difficult
i wanted to eat
so bad 10 o'clock starting from 10
o'clock like i want to eat then my wife
is experimenting with this new keto
bread using almond flour and it smells
so good and then at 11 o'clock she's
eating it and she brings it into the
office and she's eating it and i smell
it like
oh my gosh that smells so good
it's 11 o'clock i still got three more
hours until i can eat but in that period
when it's difficult when i can't do it
when i set a goal for myself that i'm
not going to eat until 2 o'clock
what happens if i eat early
just one day right just one bite just a
couple bites who cares
i lasted till 11 o'clock
what happens when you eat early
you taught yourself that you don't
follow through
i'd be reinforcing the fact that i don't
follow through and then the next time i
set a goal my brain is gonna tell me
yeah you're not gonna actually do that i
might get amped up and pumped up in the
moment to say i can do that
but the next day i'll be telling myself
now i can't do that
you never hit your goals that's the
problem that's where most people live
because until it's hard it doesn't count
because if you set a goal that's just
easy to hit that means your standards
are super low
it's not a real goal if your goal is to
to wake up and breathe today okay great
for some people that might should be
a big challenge but for most people
that's an easy thing to do
if it's an easy goal then it's not
really a goal
if it's a hard goal then it's gonna be
moments that will challenge you and what
you do in the moments that are
challenging to you is what defines you
either in a negative light or positive
one i said i was not gonna eat until two
o'clock so i had to wait
and then come two o'clock on the dot
i'm running out
getting the bread
smelling it
oh my god i can still taste it right now
and and just sitting back in the chair
and and enjoying
everything that was that almond bread
goodness
and my wife is trying to have a
conversation like i just need five
minutes just me and the bread
and it's not just enjoying the taste of
the bread
which was great and i was hungry
but it's enjoying the taste of doing the
goal
it's doing it because i said i was going
to do it and how great that feels
we need to build our self-confidence up
and that comes by when you say you're
going to do something guess what you do
it
and when it's hard you do it because you
said you were going to do it i'm going
to give you a three-step process to walk
you through this that i think will
really help you stay consistent on your
goals step number one tell yourself it
doesn't count until it's hard
i love setting goals when i'm feeling
optimistic and positive and bold and
motivated i think that's actually the
best part to set goals that's the best
time to send goals when you're feeling
optimistic positive bold and powered
that's that's the best part of you and
then your brain spends 99 of the time
talking you down from your big ambitious
goals so you set a goal for yourself
great it doesn't count until it gets
hard
tell yourself it doesn't count until it
gets hard so that when the difficulty
comes you're expecting it to come if
difficulty doesn't come your goal is too
easy this isn't being negative being
pessimistic i'm the most optimistic
person around
i know it's gonna get hard if it's not
hard my goal was too low
if at some point it doesn't get
difficult my goal was too low so
difficulty is coming for me
tell yourself that embrace it get ready
for it because when it happens like it
did for me today on my diet goal
at 10 a.m when i'm starving i tell
myself
it doesn't count unless it's hard step
two tell yourself it's the best this is
the best
you don't want an easy life you don't
want to have a life with no challenges
challenges are how you grow you want to
be a hero you want to do great things
everything that you want out of life is
on the other side of doing difficult
things this is the best this moment
where you feel weak when you feel like
you want to crumple this is the best
this moment right now for me when i'm
when i was starving and i had to wait
another four hours to eat was it four
hours
ten o'clock four hours to eat
that's the best
this is my chance this pain you're in
right now this is your chance when it's
difficult when it's hard when you want
to give up this is your chance
to show yourself and the world exactly
what you're made of this is the defining
moment right now that you get to define
for yourself what it means to be you
because i know what it means to be evan
carmichael
and now it's your time to step up
this is the best
and then step three is celebrate
celebrate
when you do something that's difficult
even if you don't crush it you just did
it then you need to celebrate we don't
celebrate enough and i'm victim of this
i don't celebrate enough i want to move
on to the next thing but where i do
celebrate is doing difficult things not
so much the winning of some award right
the youtube awards and all that stuff i
don't need to celebrate that stuff but i
celebrated
hitting my two o'clock goal right i
didn't want to celebrate hitting a
million subscribers but i want to
celebrate
waiting until two o'clock
to eat my food what you pay attention to
what you celebrate matters
i want to celebrate the things that make
me feel good about myself
and you should do
if you're doing something difficult if
you barely cross the line but you did it
when it was difficult that's not a small
win that's not just ah you barely made
it that's a holy cow are you kidding me
when it was difficult when you wanted to
quit when you went to gave up you kept
going amazing
pat yourself on the back you got to
celebrate that stuff now you can
celebrate it to yourself i i keep it all
internal i'm telling myself i'm the best
you can celebrate it online with your
friends family whatever makes the most
sense for you but celebrate it when you
got through something hard and you're
part of your effort
you deserve to celebrate
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
i'm going to teach you a mindset hack
that if you can learn to apply will help
you
eliminate your self-doubt your fears
your insecurities and step forward
confidently into whatever situation you
get yourself into and it's this
you teach yourself that you can learn
anything you can learn anything you may
not have the answers right now you may
not know how to do the crazy thing that
you want to do you've got big goals big
big dreams big ambitions you want to do
something big that's why you're watching
this channel right you're part of
believe nation you want to do something
big with your life i love it you don't
know how to do it
you teach yourself i can learn
anything
because what we often
struggle with is
you want to do something you know you
can't do it yet and then you associate
with that i suck
i can't do something so i suck
and that
attack
on your self-worth on your
self-confidence on your self-esteem
prevents you from actually going off and
creating something amazing right i think
i think you're a genius i think you have
michael jordan level talent at something
i believe that i don't just say it in
videos i believe that that's true
so whatever you're stuck on
instead of making yourself feel like you
suck that you're not good enough that
you're not capable of it
understand that it's just a skill set
that's missing the difference between
where you're at right now and where you
want to be
is the skills that you acquire and in
the action that you're taking
you're willing to take action problem is
you probably don't have the skills yet
to be where you want to be that's okay
you tell yourself i can learn anything
learning becomes your superpower i had a
guy on my instagram live not that long
ago
and
he was talking about becoming a digital
marketer and he was asking me
what
place do i sign up for a degree for
digital marketing and is it worth
getting the degree for digital marketing
because i want to i want to be a digital
marketer i want to sell my digital
marketing services to entrepreneurs
there are some fields where having a
degree is really important
digital marketing is not one of them
going to i don't even know if you can
get that in university but going to take
somebody's digital marketing
certification
is not going to be helpful for you in
terms of getting new clients you might
learn some new skills that you can use
to get new clients but he was putting
too much stock in the paper his belief
was in the paper that because he was
going to get this certification that
says that he was a digital marketer that
that would help him get more clients
now if you're going to get
a law degree or an accounting degree or
something official you know
professionals then great yes you can't
become a lawyer without going to law
school right
but digital marketing
if they're teaching at a school it's
already outdated digital marketing is
changing on the flyer i look at what i'm
doing on my youtube channel
if i was to teach a course at a youtube
conference a year ago it would be
different it's why in my youtube growth
boot camp i updated constantly with the
new things that i'm learning because it
changed from one year ago
textbooks are written like two three
four sometimes five six longer years ago
so apply the digital marketing it's
already out of date
but the problem with the guy who called
into my ig live was his faith his trust
was in the paper that having the paper
having a degree would help him get
credibility and close clients
his trust your trust your faith needs to
be in yourself
needs to be in you and your ability to
learn not in your abilities that you
have right now because you don't have
the abilities yet to do the thing that
you want to do you're not capable yet if
you were capable you would have done it
you're not ready yet that's okay but
you're able to learn you
you
you can learn anything
so whenever you're in fear and
insecurity in doubt you're not sure what
to do don't take it personally don't say
i suck as a human because i don't have
this skill set you can learn anything
remind yourself of it and then you need
to create a customized program for you
you need to create your own university
your own learning program so that every
day you're slowly acquiring that skill
that knowledge said that you're missing
it's why i created the 254 series where
every day for 254 days you get a new
video on a topic
that if you want more confidence if you
want more self love you want more
motivation you want to be a writer we've
got lots of different topics there's
hopefully something there for you but
even though i mean i may not have made
it yet right i made a whole bunch and
they're free for you but if i didn't
make it you go make your own
my youtube channel is my own that every
day i want more belief in my life and so
i created the channels for that and
hopefully that spreads and you guys like
it you're getting more belief with every
video too but you need to create your
own program
every day whatever the skill set is that
you want to learn that is the only gap
between where you are and where you want
to be because you're willing to take
action you just don't have the skill
sets yet but you're willing to learn and
you're able to learn anything you can
learn anything that needs to be on loop
in your head i can learn anything i
don't know how to do it yet but i can
learn anything
and then apply it so every day what are
you going to be learning
every day what video you're going to
watch
what book you're going to read what
podcasts you're going to listen to how
are you going to learn who are you going
to reach out to who's done the thing
that you want to do and how can you
learn from them and apply it
every day
it's there's never been more information
out there there's never been more
thought leaders experts people who've
succeeded sharing their tips their
advice their knowledge their feedback
and you can start for free before you go
and hire somebody as a as a coach
or you drop thousands of dollars on
somebody's mastermind
consume their content for free
youtube videos are free
podcasts are free
buy their book it's gonna cost 20 bucks
25 bucks right invest small make sure
you're getting knowledge that helps
make sure you're getting knowledge that
when you apply it works and then you can
start spending more but you need to see
a return on investment for every dollar
you put in for all the mentors that you
pick your time and the money that you're
putting in
you're a genius i i and i
you know a little frustrated because i
love you and i want to see you win and i
see so many talented people and believe
nation with great ideas great ambition
and great heart great heart like you
want to do great things for the right
reasons and serve the world
you just haven't learned the skills yet
and so you remind yourself i can learn
anything
whatever problem in front of me right
now
i don't have the skill sets yet
then i
can learn
anything self-improvement is the answer
to whatever obstacle is staring you in
the face right now the only difference
between you and greatness is the
willingness to grow and improve it's not
talent it's not smart it's the
willingness to improve yourself the
difference between you and tony robbins
is he has spent more time constantly
improving himself than most people on
the planet here's a guy who had multiple
fathers growing up had an abusive mother
who at 17 he had to run away from home
so he could become a janitor and never
go to college he then decided to be a
success he read 700 books in seven years
he studied under mentors like jim rohn
and today he's the founder or owner of
companies with over 6 billion
in annual revenue if tony robbins can go
from being an abused janitor with no
college education to being one of the
most influential people in the world
why can't you the difference is he made
the investment to constantly improve
himself and you haven't yet at that
level so i look at my channel as an
example my youtube channel and i've
learned so much over the past number of
years
in confidence and growth and abilities
and skills by consuming the content
because i love the top 10 series and the
meant to me series in the international
series i make them for me and then i
share them with you and thankfully you
guys like them too and i can build a
business off of it and keep pumping out
more content but it helps me i've grown
i've learned and one of the biggest
moments that helped me realize how much
i've learned is when i signed a
three-year deal with sage i was working
with stephen kelly who was the ceo and
every month we'd be on a call we'd be
doing a hangout on my youtube channel
answering questions from people and i
was driving with my dad and i remember
him asking me how do you get the
confidence to be on
a call with stephen kelly and be seen as
his equal all the time and he wasn't
asking me to put me down he was asking
me in in genuine of he was so happy for
me that i was playing a bigger game and
it dawned on me that he was right
the evan of five years ago wouldn't have
been able to do that the evidence of
five years ago would have felt less than
the evidence five years ago would have
said there's no way i'm capable of doing
that
and then when i'd signed the deal i felt
like
it's great i love stephen he's amazing
but i feel like i'm hanging out with
oprah and kanye and steve jobs and bill
gates and these super successful people
and they're infiltrating my brain on a
daily basis right a daily basis three
videos every single day on this channel
and so bit by bit it pulls me up now i
recognize i still have a long way to go
i still have so much more to learn i
still need to believe in myself even
more and every time i consume more
content it allows me to grow my comfort
zone a little bit a little bit a little
bit a little bit more and the funny
thing is all of these moments are are
little tiny incremental parts of your
growth i couldn't point you to one point
in my past where i said that was the
moment that i changed that was the
moment that i had more confidence but as
i studied every day every day every day
i could look back three months six
months a year and say wow i've really
changed i've really grown i've really
learned a lot but in the daily from
today to yesterday i'd say i didn't grow
at all and so sometimes on your journeys
you're trying to learn and get better
you may feel like the growth is really
slow on a daily basis but if you keep
going you keep investing you keep
learning you keep seeking out mentors
you keep trying to get better and
improve not every day will be amazing
but if you try every day to get better
and learn i can guarantee you that in
three months six months one year when
you look back
of the person you've become compared to
what you are right now there'll be a big
change and that's because you continue
to invest in yourself so i'm going to
give you a three-step process to how to
create a customized program for you so
that you can become world-class at the
thing that you want to be world-class at
step one decide what you want to be
world-class at you could be world-class
at a lot of things with enough energy
effort wisdom porn into you practice
repetition you can be world-class at
something but what what like what in
your core what is the thing that you
need to be world-class at what is the
burning desire in you that you say i
want to be among the best in the world
at
what
fill that in what do you want to be
world class at number two immerse
yourself in that environment the fastest
way to learn a language the fastest way
to learn japanese is not from a textbook
it's not from going to classes it's to
go to japan
you need to immerse yourself in the
environment whatever the thing is that
you want to be great at the more you are
around it people who are doing it people
who are speaking it people who are
living it the more it will rub off onto
you and the faster it will rub off onto
you now it can be a physical environment
or it could also be from the content
that you're consuming i get it a lot
from my own youtube videos because i
feel like i'm around steve jobs and elon
musk and oprah winfrey every single day
and the more you immerse yourself in
that environment the more their mindset
the more their motivation the more their
confidence is going to stick with you to
help you go be world-class the thing
that you want to be great at and then
step number three is practice every
single day you need to practice every
single day it's not enough just to be
around it you need to practice you got
to do you want to be world class at
something right that requires daily
dedication the reason why i got better
at making my content my videos is i've
done six thousand videos a thousand
videos aren't even public on my channel
we've thrown away more videos than most
people ever create on their channel and
it's not because i'm amazing go back
like i encourage you go back and look at
my first videos i sucked it was brutal
it's because i said i want to be great
at this thing and i surrendered myself
with people who could help push me and i
could learn from and then i practice
every single day the reason why i pass
people who are considered to be a lot
better than me at this is because i put
in my work because when people had a
hard time finding time to make one video
a week i was doing three a day
and if you take that same approach if
you take that same mindset of i'm just
gonna outwork everybody around me i'm
gonna outwork my competition when they
may have a hard time finding time to do
that thing that they need to get better
at once a week and you're doing it three
times a day you will blow past people
who are more naturally talented because
you have put in the work to get good at
your skill because you made it this far
in a video i want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe nation you made it here
all the way to the end and i love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
below on this video i will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because
you are awesome to see my recent
one-on-one with mel robbins check the
interview right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there i hope your business
goes bankrupt evan evan you're a
terrible person i spent the first
40 some years of my life trying to be
somebody else i'll give you guys a
secret way